Цей маленький білий гаджет здатен врятувати життя.
Він розпізнає ймовірність серцево-судинних хвороб
та надсилає на мобільний додаток попередження.
На конкурсі стартапів у Лас-Вегасі цей прилад здобув перше місце,
обійшовши понад 900 ідей.
Однак перед тим довелося здолати купу перепон вдома.
На ринку України немає належних умов
для розробки інноваційних продуктів.  Немає правової бази
для комфортного існування.
Про те, що Україна цьогоріч піднялася  на 7 сходинок
і опинилась на 43-му місці у загальносвітовому інноваційному рейтингу,
написали у своїх соцмережах і український президент, і високопосадовці.
Щоправда, заслуга влади в цьому вельми сумнівна:
серед 80 критеріїв рейтингу в Україні найбільше провисали
політичне середовище, політична стабільність та безпека,
ефективність уряду, верховенство права.
За цими показниками Україна посіла 107 місце
із 126 країн.
Скаржаться ІТ-компанії і на часті перевірки податківців
та "наїзди" чиновників.
За статистикою, понад 90 відсотків судів
виграють ІТ-компанії. Тобто це були неправомірні набіги на компанії.
Якщо іноземні партнери бачать, що таке відбувається в державі,
то який рівень довіри може бути до такої країни.
Витягнув Україну в інноваційному рейтингу
критерій "Інтелектуальні досягнення країни".
За ним Україна на 27 місці у світі.
Ідей не бракує, кажуть у компанії Concepter,
яка займається просуванням молодих стартаперів.
З останніх відкриттів - винахід школярів:
так звана безсмертна канцелярія -
зошит та олівець, що не псуються.
Утім, цьому стартапу, як і іншим, потрібна фінансова підтримка.
В Україні ж поки мало фондів, які готові фінансувати ідеї з нуля.
А держава грошима взагалі не долучається.
Про обіцяний рік тому прем'єром Володимиром Гройсманом  Фонд  підтримки стартапів
в уряді, схоже, вже забули.
Усі позитивні процеси, які відбуваються, йдуть від самих компаній,
від інвесторів, від підприємців, які роблять продукт.
Він стає більш успішним, і компанії ростуть,
і відповідно все зростає.
Ідеальна модель, про яку мріють у цьому офісі,
це коли держава та інвестори об’єднають зусилля.
Наприклад, в Ізраїлі 60% фінансування надає інвестор, решту 40 - держава.
Стимулювати ІТ-сектор має також і оновлене законодавство.
Досі так і не прописаний прозорий спосіб введення
міжнародної діяльності для українських ІТ-компаній.
Це проблема, яка живе глибоко всередині чиновників.
Вони вважають, що якщо бізнес прибутковий,
то його треба ...
чи "віджати", чи "подоїти".
Якби цього не було, то були би
більш теплі умови для ІТ-сектору
Тобто він є, але більшість фрілансерів
працюють за сірими схемами
і в Україні не показують прибуток.
Нині колеги Михайла готуються до сертифікації гаджету
у Сполучених Штатах та Європі.
Але найбільше непокояться щодо отримання сертифікату саме в Україні.
Ще одне випробування, яке українським винахідникам нелегко подолати.